welcome to CBS this morning but before  we get to today's news we're gonna make  a little bit of news on our own yes we  are we are thrilled to announce that  bianna golodryga it's joining us as  co-host of CBS this morning welcome I'm  thrilled to be here it's a trigger thank  you guys  are you really thrilled to be hi I  really am because we are really doing  that I'm really again we heard the news  and I said yippee for us yeah we're  excited that you're already known as a  first-rate journalist and you're going  to continue our mission here on this  story on this show to do  first-rate journalism original reporting  great storytelling which is what we all  strive to do the best team to work with  thanks for having me thank you